hi I'm Erik Vasa Dementors endgame is a
new update about the fate of a major
character miss pepper potts
and perhaps Tony Stark to win Paltrow
took some precious time away from
redefining wellness to say that endgame
will be her final movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
so she did hashtag spilled the pepper
confirmed there's actually a lot to dig
into here stuff that ties together with
some moments that we might have
overlooked an infinity war and some
cryptic theories about Pepper Potts and
in games Oh spoiler warning in light
that Casey ruined that one's for you
dyslexic ok Paltrow recently told
variety that Avengers endgame would be
her last Marvel film saying she's a bit
too old to be in a suit and all that at
this point but that she would be willing
to come back for a day for a cameo in a
future film who may and this is a
podcast so let's break it all down with
no no this isn't technically a tweak
down it's a whole quote in an interview
in a major publication so sure whatever
so this mean Paltrow's final film as
Pepper Potts leads to four theories for
what could happen Avengers endgame and
Marvel phase four beyond theory one
Pepper Potts dies and so does Tony Stark
Paltrow might have added this whole
future caneo option in her interview
- like backpedal from the finality of a
first statement like I could imagine
some publicist in the corner whispering
you might come back right
oh crap Holland and Ruffalo are into the
junket next door at pitchers in game
will probably be the final movie for
several long time MCU characters and
pepper is among the ones who have been
there since the beginning and if she
leaves this world I feel like it could
be in a circumstance in which Tony Stark
would - like sure I could see a scenario
where Pepper dies and then a still alive
Tony Stark is further mobilized to
Avenger but think about it Tony already
has many tragic losses to avenge adding
pepper to that death pile would be
overkill even though my cut instinct
really changes week to week right now
I'm thinking that the odds might be
better in favor of Starks survival and
that would go for pepper - so I think
we're looking at another possible fate
theory - pepper and Tony retire
retirements like death but only in terms
of your function in society we've been
getting more and more evidence that Iron
Man will survive the events of endgame
but that he might not be as active in
this marble world anymore in the trailer
for spider-man part from home which is
confirmed to take place after endgame
there are some characters who reference
Iron Man without any sense of sadness or
warning and Pepper Potts name does show
up on a charity check from Stark
Industries but Iron Man also doesn't
seem to be around to help spider-man
with happy hogan indicating that Peters
on his own now and Nick Fury having to
trust his remaining eye on a new person
get out of here so we could be looking
at a post stark world in which he's just
retired and not just an environment
three retired like maybe the events of
endgame will force Tony Stark to
permanently retire like part of some
bargain to save the Fallen could require
the old man to hang up the arc reactor
for good early in Avengers infinity war
Tony and pepper talk about his return
from retirement competing with his
desire to settle down and build a family
Pepper hinted that she wasn't pregnant
in that scene but Paltrow has said in
past interviews that they have a child
on the way
this is before Infinity Ward came out
but they shot Infinity Ward in game at
the same time so maybe Paltrow was
referring to some epilogue scene an end
game in which she and Tony have settled
down with a kid actually when Yuri watch
that scene at the beginning of infinity
war a new possible interpretation begins
to emerge last night I dreamt we had a
kid so real we named him after your
eccentric Uncle Bob what was his name
Morgan
hmm what if this dream that Tony had was
actually a vision a memory rippling from
another timeline 33 Tony and pepper live
on in an alternate timeline ventures in
game will most likely features some kind
of timeline meddling either through
time-travel or multiverse hopping
something using the chaotic physics of
the quantum realm check out any number
of past videos that we made on this
subject perhaps Tony Stark's vivid dream
of having a child with pepper is
actually a real memory echoing from
another reality a new timeline of events
that will be created through the events
of endgame the Avengers lost to Thanos
could all just be part of a darkest
timeline hashtag darkest timeline please
come see my show a darkest timeline that
Ironman and the rest will have to erase
or rewrite with a new happy ending
timeline in which Tony and pepper have
this kid
Morgan Stark and Morgan is an
interesting name option because it can
be a boy or girl's name and Catherine
Langford has been were
portably cast in an unknown role in
endgame maybe it's Morgan Stark the
future teenage daughter of Tony and
pepper that way the Iron Man mantle
could live on with a new generation but
there's another way the Iron Man legacy
could live on that could explain my
Paltrow and pepper are retiring from the
MCU
theory for Pepper Potts moves up to a
new Super role there's another scene
early an infinity war with pepper that
might give us a clue of her role in
endgame notice when Tony tries to
communicate with her after boarding
ebony mom's cue ship peppers last words
to him kind of interesting going to what
hashtag pepper potts going to Disneyland
confirmed in that first endgame trailer
Tony did drop another interesting line
for being adrift space was zero the
promise of rescue is more fun that
sounds sea rescue is the name Pepper
Potts goes under in the comics link she
fills in for Tony with her own armor and
as the name rescue implies conducts a
series of rescue based and humanitarian
missions Paltrow's recent variety
interview included the cryptic detail
that she felt too old to be in the suit
maybe she was referring to that time
when she wore the armor an Iron Man 3 or
maybe she's referencing the new armor
that she was seen wearing in a leaked
and game wardrobe photo or maybe she's
referencing an upcoming goop article
titled ladies hang up those Blazers by
40 but it sounds like Pepper Potts will
play more of an active role in in game
than she has in past Marvel appearances
she could become a rescue figure putting
out fires in a far-off corner of the
globe kind of like war machine slash
iron patriot has been described doing in
the past or she could run off and join
the Nova Corps in Star Force
some Supergirl a gig that takes are far
away and lets a return for the
occasional cameo which fate do you want
Pepper Potts to have an endgame and in
phase 4 comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on twitter and
instagram @ ee vas and subscribe to this
channel new rock stars and subscribe to
new rockstars podcasts wherever you
listen to podcasts and if you live in
the LA area come check out my nerdy
goofy comedy show darkest timeline
comedy Friday March 1st in every first
Friday at the Acme comedy theater in
North Hollywood ticket info in the
description below thank you for watching
now let's keep refreshing goop to see if
a rescue armored suit shows up
sale only costs 36 million dollars
that's a steal